je joue mes trois dernières dates de
spectacles en décembre 2016 au zénith de
paris
j'aime plus trop ce mot draguer ça ça
fait un peu fort soeur moi ce dont j'ai
envie d'en parler c'est la séduction
naturelle
d'ailleurs j'ai failli appeler cette
vidéo la séduction naturelle mais ça
faisait un peu film français de la
nouvelle vague
la séduction naturelle un film de jean
luc godard
alors j'essaie d'appeler séduire au
naturel et ça faisait un peu boîtes de
thon séduire au naturel du coup je
l'appelle tout simplement technique de
drague 3 même si ça fait un peu rauque
et pour séduire une femme faut tout
simplement être soi même
discret et charmant on n'est pas des
sauvages on n'est pas des chasseurs le
chant sont les réactions fusent il
chausse mon fusil de chasse et le pc est
qu à part lui apparemment envie quand tu
veux plaire une fille on s'est tous dit
rien de mieux que d'être un gentleman
des petits riens de galanterie mine de
rien ça peut tout changer
madame norman c'est ma veste
oui ça c'est avait ce jeu tantôt absolut
eu la maîtrise que tu vas donc on disait
quand tu veux draghi faut pas écouter
les conseils des autres la réponse elle
est dans son coeur merci à tous pourtant
on a tous ce mode qui se prend pour rich
et qui veut donner des conseils en
séduction comme si tu étais un gros
puceau pour séduire les femmes c'est
qu'il personnes c'est la confiance en
soit parce qu'elles veulent c'est un
[ __ ] de mal
tout simplement mais ce mec là tu as
juste envie de lui dire je lisais toi
t'as jamais vu tim wes que moi en fait
de avec moi par amoureux ouais je veux
bien la confiance en soi c'est vraiment
le ba ba je tombais sur des sites qui
explique à des mecs et quels
comportements à avoir pour séduire mais
les conseils qui donne sur ce site c'est
quand même des grosses évidence avoué
des petits défauts pas des trucs qui
font flipper du genre je suis violent
quand je bois je viens de sortir de
prison
ça paraît assez évident que c'est
vraiment les pierres arguments du monde
pour draguer quoi c'est les bons rôles
bof qui interpelle les meufs dans la rue
et puis qui les insultes je me laissais
sénat et se prennent tellement des gros
râteau tout le temps que si un jour une
meuf accepte ça va donner ça à ce qu'ils
mangent et boivent à trouve ça me fait
plaisir
toi aussi tu es mignon en fait tu jamais
arriver à cette étape donc je sais pas
quoi dire
parce que moi est selon de bois sans
autant moi dans la vie je suis nul pour
faire des recherches sur internet
je n'ai pas la fibre de la recherche
mais quand il s'agit de retrouver sur
facebook une meuf t'a croisés en soirée
alors là nous les mecs on se transforme
clairement en agent de la cia
ok les gars je commençais tout le
périmètre des amis en commun avec elle
d'après nos meilleurs souvenirs avant
qu'on soit bourré elle portait un haut
rouge avec des pois blancs et des
énormes seins et son visage chef
elle avait les énormes ça ok d'après nos
sources c'est la botte de la botte de la
meuf qu'organiser la soirée nos petits
gars ont réussi à dénicher une vidéo
amateur revenez en arrière fait un zoom
x 8 fait 425 / 32
abonnez-vous la chaîne norman fait des
vidéos chanter les premières notes de la
vie en rose
comment décrire ce sens comme un pôle
image voilà les chefs mais c'est ma
femme ça ok bobby en année de
l'opération fait quand même une petite
capture d'écran avec deux trophées du
taux plein pour moi pour le dossier des
archives de ma [ __ ] la chute bien
vulgaire qui va rien plaire à papa et
maman comptes qui te plaît physiquement
c'est vrai que la vie de tes potes sur
son physique bizarrement il assez
importants comme si on avait besoin
d'une sorte de validation tu as tu en
penses quoi
et pas enfin en fait changé d'avis je
casse tout le monde dragouille un peu
sur snapshot tu vois tu envoies un petit
coeur tu montes tu habites ça fait
plaisir
par contre le mode vidéo il est très
dangereux histoire vraie récemment j'ai
présenté une fille que j'aimais bien à
mes potes viasna
mais ils n'ont pas eu la réaction que
j'attendais je vous présente elodie une
grosse [ __ ]
la nouveau en fait un salut mon amour je
t'aime moi j'ai pas trop de conseils à
donner en séduction a par contre je peux
vous déconseiller des trucs par exemple
si vous comptez séduire une meuf en
soirée je vous déconseille vial avec un
pote trop beau si ce mec que toutes les
meufs kif
parce que à côté de lui à la soirée bat
a juste l'air d'un meuble
ce n'était pas lui mais caracalla
as tu pars de norman niamey wall street
est d'ailleurs
de toute façon beau pas tout ça c'est
très superficiel et puis comme on dit
tous les goûts sont dans la nature
donc peu importe votre physique peu
importe à quoi vous ressemblez ils tous
bien qu'un jour ou l'autre vous tomberez
forcément sur une femme qui vous
correspond
tu
et en tue
et sinon tu fais quoi dans la vie ben
moi j'ai chez ikea depuis deux ans la
nôtre millions
donc soutien à tous ceux qui comme moi
sont des bons gros meubles en soirée
hashtag étagères hashtag commode
merci d'avoir regardé ma vidéo j'espère
qu'on va se revoir très bientôt
parce que vraiment je vous aime tous
mais genre à la folie non mais vraiment
je suis amoureux donc j'espère a très
vite et si ça vous a plu mettez un pouce
en l'air pour l'amour de l'homme
se faire recaler du tapis rouge donne
voilà voilà
bon bah finalement ne pas rentrer parce
que
le film était pas ou quoi on voulait
plus voir un club